la derecha gana terreno en Suecia la
coalición conformada por cuatro partidos
los moderados los demócratas cristianos
los liberales y los demócratas de Suecia
se llevaron una muy estrecha mayoría
controlarían 176 escaños de los 349 del
parlamento la coalición de Centro
izquierda se queda con 173 la primera
ministra Magdalena Anderson reconoció la
derrota y anunció su dimisión la mayoría
de las encuestas de opinión nos
mostraron que habría una carrera reñida
sabía que esto podría suceder pero por
supuesto estoy preocupada el mandato de
Anderson corto y convulso pasa a la
historia por ponerle punto final a la
política sueca de no alineamiento y
presentar la postulación para entrar a
la otan en las urnas la percepción de
inseguridad y el sentimiento anti
inmigrante dominaron el debate como en
esta localidad de 20.000 habitantes al
sur del país donde casi la mitad de la
población apoyó a los demócratas de
Suecia un permitido que encuentra sus
raíces en movimientos supremacistas los
habitantes dicen estar hartos de la
inmigración que según ellos es la
causante de la delincuencia
Si consideras que en su conjunto hemos
sufrido mucho más por la inmigración que
el resto de Suecia y esto ha traído
crimen ahora
de los moderados dijo que se prepara
para formar gobierno se debe establecer
el resultado definitivo si tenemos los
requisitos previos parlamentarios me
reuniré con todas las facciones
políticas para cooperar estoy listo para
hacer todo lo que pueda para formar un
nuevo gobierno estable y vigoroso pero
christisterson aún debe esperar hasta
que se ha anunciado oficialmente la
victoria quedan pocos votos por contar
pero no suficientes para invertir la
tendencia